et la sixième semaine de l'industrie
c'est en ce moment et jusqu'au 20 mars
la chambre de commerce et de l'industrie
de versailles continue ses actions pour
cet événement ce rendez vous permet au
grand public en particulier aux jeunes
de découvrir à l'industrie et ses
métiers en rencontrant ses acteurs pour
mieux appréhender les enjeux de la
filière mardi 15 mars
elle proposait à une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs et d'entreprises du
réseau coaction yvonne de rencontrer une
centaine de lucien élèves en bts du
lycée villa roi chaque représentant
d'entreprises échangé avec six élèves
pendant près de 20 minutes
andrea doria animatrice du réseau qu'aux
actions pour la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles vinh vous en
parle écoutez la du côté des entreprises
il aime beaucoup échangé avec les gens
de leur faire comprendre la réalité du
monde de l'entreprise du monde de
travail les savoirs être au travail les
savoir-être aux entreprises leur
apprendre voilà qui a un parcours je
n'ai pas écrit et que ça s'écrit petit à
petit du côté des
et des jeunes ben il aime beaucoup le
porte unités de rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprise des différentes entreprises
des différentes activités qui peuvent
leur apporter une idée différente à
celle qui reçoit en cours ça nous permet
de découvrir des entrepreneurs qui ont
réussi à faire leur vie enfin commencé
comme nous il tenait le préciser entre
octobre propre entreprise ou évoluer
dans l'entreprise à l'accueil on
commenté